guy greece celebrating today but the
thing is what happens later today and
what happens in the days to come the
bank is going to be pivotal in this rich
this is going to be one of the key
questions over the next few days down as
far a fracas the finance minister
promised me last week back in the last
week the Greek banks would reopen
tuesday that's going to be quite a
difficult task to achieve I think we're
going to watch later on we've got this
meeting between angular Merkel and
Francois Hollande that's going to really
set the tone the ECB meeting was in the
morning it's been moved in the afternoon
they're looking for political cover from
those two leaders what will they do with
the ELA the ECB has a big decision to
make today does it increase the LA does
it hold the LA this is emergency
liquidity for the Greek bags the talk is
that they're going to run out of money
midweek unless you see the ECB stepping
up so the ECB a big part of this story
the bank's a big part of this story yes
there's celebration but if the banks
don't open it'll be empty to see how
Greece ultimately works its way through
this week great rich erratic hapless
that's what he was being caught in the
days up to the calling that referendum
and now people saying is he the great
gambler is he actually really ass dude
well I think he was a great gamle took a
huge risk mr. see Paris was in a really
difficult position his party was
beginning to fragment there was internal
dissent what did he do he pulled a
left-field move and he went with a
referendum he's now got the backing of
the Greek people serezha is coming back
together again that dissent is
disappearing and it does put them in a
stronger position the question is is
this simply though just entrench the
current positions that we have with
grease on one side feeling confident
with mr. tsipras feeling confident and
the creditors and the other side say you
know what you're not making any of the
kind of commitments that we want you to
make how does that get resolved very
difficult to see at this stage how
ultimately that one ends very difficult
to see angular Merkel who has her own
constituency that she's got to deal with
as well giving massive concessions just
because the Greek people of term rally
gone we don't want any more austerity